because you've got an exception that's a
gray area that's the Venn diagram I was
just I was just trying to be funny I was
just I was just trying to be funny yeah
but there's some truth in it because
you're just saying do you know what
because because in a new case version
like you don't know you're never gonna
no you don't so so what I'm saying is
like I actually I actually would like
well I don't think knowing what I know
now but that's not a real situation
right so like like and honestly like I
don't think we have the right to play
God because that's what you're doing
you're playing God but then do you
believe that that all depends on if you
believe in God that really I do yeah
yeah that's true that's true and without
care or concern is the very definition
of irresponsible here in the UK they are
so I was a sexual health advisor I
worked for bpass I help women
um access abortions uh here in the UK
they are so that's probably a yeah yeah
so yeah okay wait these these might be
towards you because my audience is more
like agreeing with me no that's
absolutely fine reproductive
responsibility or lack thereof is
clearly illustrated by many articles
such they're of the University of
Massachusetts Medical School titled who
are these four American women who chose
chose the reasons again it's very U.S
yeah it's very U.S based whereas I am UK
a lot of my background in research
that's it Professor Roger Ingram and
Professor Claire Hart if you look at
their work in the psychology of
attractivism relationships and
psychology of sexual health and
reproduction that's where a lot of my
bias comes from so you know I
acknowledge my bias I acknowledge and I
I acknowledge your difference like
obviously your experience your knowledge
um I'm not going to argue with you I'm
gonna say yeah cool like yeah difference
I'm comfortable with it like okay the
the faster child who is forced to be
born because they weren't asked let's
turn that around maybe the fetus within
the womb wants to be born but the
selfish woman overvalues themselves over
the child and it beforehand
but then we can ask is it a selfish man
that wants to inside you like that
there's a lot of things
there's a lot there's a lot of I'm
saying like but then and that's it it's
really not black and white because then
we'll get men who are like oh you're
pregnant you want but I want that kid
and then it's like well wait wait a
minute it's not your do you think do you
think your mom should I was saying
like I'm gonna be real no no I'm gonna
be real no because it's not your body I
would then say
which I kind of locally agree with then
men should be able to opt out of
fatherhood responsibility in the eyes of
the law
you agree with that I do agree with that
if a man didn't want to become a father
and oh it's real oh so for example so
here's the thing no no wait so so here's
the thing right here's the thing right I
knock you up you get pregnant I don't
want the kid you want the kid right I am
saying I should be able to go you know
what I want nothing to do with that kid
and you cannot legally take me to court
for any child support for any help
whatsoever right I have the option to
opt out a father do you agree with that
I went Hey look
I said I'm gonna get pregnant
and you went ahead with it no but then
they're still that's still technically
on me to be like if you went okay I'm
gonna anyway and then I'd be like well
no Amy like you need to we do all need
to prioritize our own self-interest so
I'm personally like I'm quite
responsible in there I'm like you know
what it's on me I'm I'm not gonna drag
anyone I'm not gonna like it's on me to
deal with my own [ __ ] so I would
personally be like yeah like and
especially when that's why a lot of
people choose single Parenthood
um if someone gets you pregnant not
particularly though like because you can
go after a man's Financial like I mean
girls are trying yeah they're trying to
get they're trying to get kids I do
think that's the minority that are
trying to like trap a man I'll be honest
I've had
two women in my life and I guess isn't a
lot but I've had two women try and trap
me before
and if they got pregnant by me I
wouldn't be able to opt out of
fatherhood or responsible I mean I
wouldn't anyway but I'm just saying like
I what I'm trying to say is it it
not that it happens a lot but I'll be
honest like yeah I'm an actor I can do
well but I'm not a superstar by any
means but purely because of where they
perceive I am or what I can do and they
were older as well they were like well I
know that if I trap this guy like I I
know he'll he can provide for me do you
know what I mean and I'll be honest that
is actually a really big reason why
I've been more selective with who I get
myself involved in
because I feel like I'm getting to that
point where the age of women that I'm
dating now
that's within the realm of their
Consciousness does that make sense it's
so it's so crazy like if you're saying
that you know especially if you're
dating older women um to a point where
they're like I need security yeah
I don't so I'm not sure if you answered
the question do you think that's fair
though like so if a woman I don't think
it's fair so I don't know I'm saying
like do you think they should legally he
could say like let's say he he gets you
pregnant
he he can legally say look I want her to
get an emotion she has a choice to get
it she's not getting it no I want to opt
out of the financial responsibility I
know I think it's all on the woman I'm
like you you seriously you agree you
agree yeah okay you're a grown woman at
that point that if you want the kid or
you don't want the kid respectfully [ __ ]
what the guy thinks and I know that oh
he's half of like there's a lot of
things that come into it but I'm but
it's like yeah I'm asking about the
money part you're okay so like he he
pays nothing
if if I get pregnant and a man is like I
don't want anything to do with this kid
I'm not gonna go back and be like oh
well you didn't wrap up you didn't I'll
be like nope this is on me this is my
decision I'm gonna own it
no no I'd be like okay as far as I'm
aware my kid doesn't have a dad as far
as I'm aware I I am the one parent
that's that's my personal like thing
yeah yeah I wouldn't do it and I I
personally think that women that do that
I'm like
um I I think it's more selfish to be
like well you want this kid this is this
is your
this is how your life is but no I'm
personally like if a guy got me pregnant
and was like I don't know so we agree
there yeah yeah something we agree 100
I'd be like I'd be like like you've got
to own your own [ __ ] at the end of
the day because yeah the only person you
ever have 100 in your life is yourself
so you gotta own your [ __ ] you gotta
back your [ __ ] but then you've got
to like we're not all victims we're not
yeah and so it's like so yeah so you
agree that it's it's the majority of the
woman's fault if you get pregnant like
it's it's your own fault I think I think
fault is the wrong word I would use but
in terms of responsibility
responsibility responsibility of choice
responsibility of choice so it's your
fault no no because fault fault is
negative connotations so responsibility
to your choice it's your body and so if
you were like let's say you're in a
loving relationship yeah and you get
pregnant and the guy's like well I
really want to be a dad at that and you
really don't want to carry a baby's a
term you really don't want to lose your
job you don't want to do this you then
have to decide and if he's like if if
he's like well I'll leave you and I'll
be full betrayed you then have to decide
okay do I care more about him and our
relationship or do I care more about
myself and it's like we have got we've
got autonomy we've got Choice we've got
responsibility and I think that we need
to stop pretending that women are like
pathetic or need a man or XYZ it's like
no baby back yourself
we do we don't need them because they do
no because they're lesbians who do you
who do you call to get your car fixed a
man or a woman your toilet breaks down
who do you call so I fix my own car I
can I can do it I'm motor mechanics my
power as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible